romance is invited at the shearing
includes really like this shock your
super fruit and sparkling wine at
arrival and 4pm like check out what is
that sound man hashtag [ __ ] Rob next
next episode next episode of hashtag
[ __ ] that noise comic store I saw salad
Jules phase like are we really gonna do
this again but that's like it was for
the whole question what I love I love
Rob I love Rob oh oh that whole [ __ ] CBC
thing yeah we're gonna do I was drowning
it to [ __ ] Rob whatever it wouldn't be
the first time oh that's do too bro the
chest imminent hashtag [ __ ] Rob please
thank you two guys are jerks I'm just
gonna get know what I'm going to call
you guys will pick it up on your own I'm
just gonna go work on the script oh no I
no Trent flipped at hashtag [ __ ] so
I'm doing a I'm doing a script on
omega-level mutant let me do the podcast
let's just eat here chat with everyone
today yeah like I'm doing a script on
Ice Man being omegan level and it's
literally like ice man has powers and
then suddenly he's it'll make a level
view then that's it oh yeah that's per
day it's like really I just hope the
whole chat is hashtags now funny how
that happens you mentioned one hashtag
only know the hashtag [ __ ] your favorite
youtuber looks like so this all is
actually the sub tweeted you what again
yeah barely Tyrone Magnus said his
review on Deadpool he's like how much
explained is [ __ ] amazing and I was
like oh so she seems like an extreme I
know more sub to each other for a long
goddamn chopped liver you know who i am
i'm almost as bad as Cape Joel oh but
but jump yeah I knew anyone nobody's
like let's go be friends with Benny like
you wonder why i don't need no freakin
friends you're so full of [ __ ] i sow
schalke house in my court season 1 of
this dudes like he wants to like talking
to hang out and like you don't talk and
hang out you
it's all mopey its eyes its finest
snowboarding all day Alberto popped up
on monster and Red Bulls when we were in
Los Angeles c'mon tied up you get all
mopey and sad because I wasn't like hey
let's go hang out and talk but here's
the cool for the always a shower hashtag
[ __ ] I'm just gonna start poking the
bear until I find so oh that's oh by the
way that that last hashtag was brought
to you by hashtag [ __ ] comic book club a
club lounge with come did you know what
I love more than anything is being able
to like write all of this off it's not
Isis through I mean like this a great
yes the first year I got to do that I
was like hashtag [ __ ] monster red bull
hashtag Raja but we actually had a
really intelligent conversation last
week in the post show when we talked
about you know being professional
youtubers and writing stuff off but not
be stopped for a loss so if you want to
buy a house or something what exact this
literally like everything from March
22nd 27th will be tax deductible yeah
like because we're gonna come on to the
podcast i'm gonna be like hey guys
here's what we did in Los Angeles and I
making money off it means it's not
deductible so that's gonna be a cool
thing like they don't have like a whole
like relaxation spa Packard's no so
Rob's wearing a Pikachu hat everybody's
gonna be a long time ever since their
sins like my camera showed up and it's
like this giant yellow thing on my head
most people noticed there was this
rocket fabulous lightly comes to what
what the hell were top of the hash okay
I would explain the story from my point
of view hashtag explain how explain
hashtag explain so good fortune of the
hashtag Rob please tell us roses oh okay
all the solutions ready to the back man
welcome to the weekly poll we're back
with your original co-host that we only
like cuz we don't like anyone who didn't
show up cuz they didn't show up it is
Betty the comic story it is a cell from
coming pop it is Ralph and comic
explained and is the most amazing the
most incredible the best member of the
entire team ever the greatest comic book
youtuber know
it kind hey Joel nothing yeah George but
you're supposed to be like ya know
lastly I but thank you there's no so
like celebrate or something it's
supposed to cut your charity is dial is
it really like you're sure you're
streaming from a swamp right now hey Meg
crappy Canadian internet and snow stars
what can I tell you stream another
friend boo I like Alex I like how people
are looking at my windows quick launch
don't like Benny as a calculator he has
battled yeah oh I remember battle.net
man like I'd go into starcraft starcraft
so reason it's like noobs only like man
I miss those days look for those you
guys wondering that's google chrome that
is tweet Twitter that is no pattern that
is status keeper that is ncsoft that is
media file what song is I don't even
know that's a be writing script
hopefully we came out of money it's
called vital reports this is Lois Lane
skis um that's a calculator I was doing
math on a bunch of crap we're doing math
sucks tiny popular and that has happened
to battlenet that is a notepad I was
writing a script what was I writing
let's see here Batman quickie um and
that is OBS now as i promised i am going
to explain my side of the hashtag [ __ ]
cbc joke that started last week and you
guys blow out of proportion long story
short the joke was aimed at Joel Joel we
love Joel basically had no bad ill
tidings with our mean or come ova cast
in any way shape or form so it became an
ongoing joke that Joel was saying
hashtag [ __ ] CBC are mean total never
say like we were all attacking him he
got you upset about it I apologize the
joke kept going he got upset about it we
i we don't do twitter twitter drama we
don't do comedy drama so as he as drama
was starting to come up because he was
getting upset over the situation Rob
blocked in from LA leaving comments and
I blocked him on Twitter to stop any
drama our mean has means to contact both
of us that is it there's no more drama
to it there's no diff Great Divide going
in the comical community that everyone
seems
think is going on there is no ulterior
motive in which we all hate our mean no
one here has any problems that I mean at
all or comical cast it was a joke that
is it until civil war comes out and we
want to build this up into an emotional
thing in which King he's so too early
for it yet so we're for those are guys
that I shall I CBC that is for Joel or I
mean to tell you not for me right Hank
you having social housing so Joel why
are you see what's going on hey we've
got a lot of good comic news to cover
this week oh man let's do it up okay i
guess i guess we go to the docket but i
did what i wanted to clarify that that
was it cuz everyones all like what is
pretty hater mean what do joel say
you're just fighting the community no
you're not no one hates anybody you want
to see me divide a community haha the
flood Rob talk about his opinions on
various other common big youtubers rubs
like what what dude that would be a
series of shows that wouldn't just be
one show what where do you think [ __ ]
that noise came from yeah really I was
literally just like I was just irritated
about something I was like you know what
I'm just gonna rant sounds like hashtag
[ __ ] that noise of people were like this
is amazing and I was like okay okay then
this genre shooters are you get your
wait wait two seconds review of Deadpool
without spoilers go [ __ ] cool
completely different from all the other
comic book movies that will come out
this year in a good way it's the best
Marvel movie that Marvel isn't making
meaning only of Hollywood's really solid
it is very soft really good just as very
it was it you know I liked the best and
I can say this without like ruining it
it it's not it's a perfect
re-imagination of Deadpool and what he
is for the comic book-like world but now
for superhero movies it's almost like
very well and it's not cuz it's not like
he makes references to like the issue of
New Mutants when he first appeared he
doesn't make comic book reference he
makes comic book movie references yeah
it breaks the fourth wall there and it's
it's a perfect
translation that said there were moments
where it looked like the comic book came
to freaking one yep my mat freeze-frame
in the truck was I leave the oven there
was a moment where he's like just some
fights like on the street where it just
looks like a comic book happening in
front of me well the old is like a book
yeah I've never seen a better comic book
adaptation of a suit yet no then get a
good one yeah what's genius about that
suit is that because it covers his whole
mouth that they have a funnier joke they
want a dub in later they can double your
joking later exactly no it's gold it's a
lot of people are saying that it's like
it's it's hollow or it's like flimsy or
its misogynist and it's like yeah you
know I think it knows what it is and
it's not trying to be anything else it's
a movie that would have blown my mind if
I was 13 but I'm older and I still
really enjoy yeah it'll I I think it
allows you to be a 13 year old again yes
it appeals to the 13 year old inside all
of us exactly and I think it's a great
gateway to an already Wolverine movie of
Vicki's many many please do cuz i will a
saying like that like fox made the
announcement there's gonna be an already
Wolverine I think today and it's not
even the second weekend the Deadpool's
been out there's there's a whole arms
race starting now for our 80 comic book
movies Todd McFarlane came out to them
I'm finished a spawn script everybody we
were something says finishes his Tomic
bronze finish that spawn script every
five years he's like oh you know I got a
spot script and guess what he's gonna be
a reuben millage and mighty to be a
fairy living in Fairyland yeah yeah I'm
down for that I'd watch that movie what
it's like a fairyland movie they made a
90 97 only really good yeah oh yeah
properly that's the only done was like
maybe hat like maybe a little bit more
money and and McFarlane's like I'm gonna
direct it I'm like oh I i love he's
threatening that they we will have a
spawn sequel even if i have to direct it
myself don't do it anyone who knows that
a direct will do it for you Todd oh my
god so rumor shooting around that Sony
or marbles like hey you know we were
pitching a dub n a movie a while back
maybe now is the time for venom guy
no maybe now is not the time for venom
maybe okay this see that brings us into
one of our one of our part one of our
discussions while we were in topic oh
yeah you get sensible right ignored
those yeah like mr. top one of our
discussion topics plastic [ __ ] Joe
that's fine I deserve I'll take that so
so Fox comes out like an this and as
soon as I saw that like it since I saw
the article because I'd seen I posted
the article last time yeah and as soon
as I saw it Fox was like you know we're
kicking around the idea of a rated r
movie it's like whoa obviously since
Deadpool did so well who didn't see that
coming you know that's like some MSC i
am with james gunn because james gunn
came out and James Gunn said right Ike
they're gonna lose they're gonna they're
gonna they're not gonna understand the
reason for their success Deadpool did
well because it was so different from
all the other ones that we're going to
see the shoe not because it was rated R
being rated R just added to it it had a
pimple to be allowed him to be to be
dead brought to be able to be Deadpool
not just ate there wasn't master made it
to be pegged on screen yeah and
Wolverine will do that like with
Wolverine being rated R will get to see
a lot more cotuit us violence and we saw
the movie the problem is they Fox will
still be the ones running the show
Deadpool was good because Fox wasn't
running the show will rain probably
won't be good because Fox will be
running this yeah I mean that's my take
i could be wrong and I don't mean it's
not saying she's very painful wonderfox
yeah well I fear a Dead Pool C I I was
looking at the budget for Deadpool and
it's under seasons under 60 million
dollars which means there's no way that
Fox will make a Deadpool sequel for
under a hundred million dollars which is
which is mistake number one yeah I mean
nobody will get another CGI superhero by
like Doug colossi thought it looked fine
especially for Coco I died in it no
problem with it for sometimes he's
clearly like a puppet yeah it's
interesting that he never powers down
for the movie that's why does Howard
don't Colossus heard about that though I
don't spoil anything go that's fun yeah
i'm just lazy to eat that it is very
first scene he's eating cereal powered
on what do you do n-no I I want to see
you know be cool more than two x-men
know that the greatest joke Jim
we need to move away from Deadpool topic
because this is just gonna turn into an
episode just called Deadpool hashtag
Deadpool and just well I assumed either
the end of this episode or the next one
was going to be a spoiler cast okay no
one likes it's gonna be a spoiler cast
or we can probably do a Saturday or
Sunday when I get back let's go to Vegas
guys I was snowboarding all morning and
now I'm going to Vegas wow you do about
it all on black and let it ride yeah
hashtag living the dream never the dream
and also you can play some street
fighter later today too that's not good
really see I was all excited for that
through there's no arcade mode Oh what
the story mode doesn't exist so what
they did was they gave you prequel
chapters which you'll get to 24 chata
fights single fights with the gate with
the computer on automatically uneasy
with no way to actually change the
difficulty um and only a single fight
then you have a survival mode no arcade
mode for online modes that is it at
Martin we're getting challenges in a few
other modes but no listing them in our
cade mode and then in July we get the
real story mode still no listings of an
arcade you mean the mode that everyone
likes and everyone plays rotating the
game like would ya is everyone asking
how we afford to afford a la crème it's
actually not youtuber life for that for
legitimately we get invited to these
things and they send us out there you
guys get invited to those things and Sal
and I ride your coattails all the way
soon but but that's because I live down
the street so you just get it yeah we
didn't you just get a season pass at the
beginning of the year for like 30 bucks
and you just go to the mountain whatever
you like oh yeah I like Betty said
that's like sorry guys I might be a
little late for the show time on the
mountain and I'm like what are you
training with reishi al Ghul and they
can alliance or something and like no
wait Colorado snowboard I know we have
had a season pass this November whenever
this free time I just go over there
snowboard what is that fresh powder it
was awesome it's awesome ride the powder
dude so ya comic news the first big
thing I think we should all talk about
it happened yesterday but the first part
of what will be a two-part new trailer
for daredevil season to hit and wow what
a what a trailer almost ninety percent
from the Punisher
jon bernthal point of view it was
amazing is so well done all to teach all
of the hate that do the hottest line
from the whole trailer is when he says
you knock them down they get back up I
knock them down and they stay down and I
was like eight how Punisher is that it's
aerated it's so much i hope that they
don't demonize him i know it's funny to
say cuz he's basically living day won't
cuz they want to spin him off into
another show it's clear they want yeah
like he's I mean he I think they're
setting up to be the antagonist of the
show but I want him to I want there to
be like two sides so that like if you
agree with Punishers tactics you're like
yeah putter sure keep going and if
you're not you're like men mad beat that
guy like I want I want there to be two
camps hopefully they do it well they
know what they're doing i don't i don't
need to [ __ ] worry about that yeah
they have no idea i think they did you
not see the first daredevil it was
horrible it was such a yam all the same
thing i still haven't finished it okay
whose steel Ferrari latina saw the same
face oh I didn't seen that yet uh yeah
what every good as bad as you think it
is nevermind i was every day to see you
tomorrow what what comedy sequels are
actually as good or better than the
original except for like 22 jump street
and stuff like that i can't think uh not
very many man but this one was so far
bad that it wasn't even it's so after
the fact like woo really wanted a new
Zoolander now in 2016 then yeah yeah ben
stiller wanted it oh yeah I can't think
of anybody in that general public who
was like we need another Ben Stiller
movie like we need another I can't think
of like anybody who was saying that they
just mean I don't think anyone is saying
that that isn't related to him hey can
you make more movies cuz like we're
running out of money you need his wife
and his father who show up in all of his
movies yeah his wife from hey dude and
his dad and dodgeball wait hey dude yeah
that show for Nickelodeon I was greatest
wife is melody watch out for those
killer cacti and man-eating Jackrabbits
not Christine Taylor
shorts come on everyone yeah there's a
reference let's just talk about 90 shows
this what I could I'm gonna be the I we
have no Faust I'm Faust affecting this
podcast yeah i was born in 1999 like
look you hey man destroyed the audience
did you ever notice that rocko's modern
life was really a postmodern life wrong
that's weird I guessed what I was gonna
say if we've said all that there is to
say about daredevil yo that's cool great
sounds awesome let me also also a like
or a believer as bad as the first one
yeah I bad being good that is so bad so
but I hope it's phat with a pH to this
oh oh we went there I did I did I went
there droptop Brokeback and how ready
for the next topic Wow which is the TC
Reaper not a reboot we were they have
crowd and greatest line ever that was
when I was literally I just had these
images of like Geoff Johns showing up to
the DC office and just he's like
slightly drunk he's as a long night and
like some some editors just sitting
there and they're like boss boss
everyone's calling this a read a reboot
they're all tell reboot and he's like it
never was a rien never it not of oyster
it's not a reboot and it never never won
but it happens wheats tweet that see
that he just heard screaming I'm like I
swear to God if you do not put that on a
poster you're fired his Green Lantern
hat is all crumbly he's so mad he throws
his captain cold action figure across
the road yeah dude okay so I'm stuck in
a house about that and for those of you
guys that have sensitive ears couple
years for the next couple seconds
talking about stuff that and I was like
you know what it feels like it feels
like like to take Vinnie's lead it's
like like Jeff Jeff like you realize I
keep saying rivers like really for
Christ's sake it's not a [ __ ] reboot
you know and then literally just like it
was like them putting on there just like
a giant it's not a reboot [ __ ] you yeah
that's how it felt well it's just like I
get I thought me it made me sad that DC
needed to write that because you know
they've been inundated would spit what
that's what comics
come though doesn't have to be like they
say local maybe they're gonna do
whatever they want to do regardless
people think like we think that we have
influence and like firstly we have
influence on is like their damage
control measures they're gonna make
decisions and maybe they'll like be
implemented for long for short period of
time dcu clear example you know we all
were like we were we were gonna get DC
whether we wanted to or not it was just
that the numbers said nobody wants it
that's the motive here yeah but new 52
they're gonna do it whether they wanted
to or not and guess what it worked out
so we're gonna keep it forever but like
with this a DC with his rebirth thing it
was like rebirth we just want to tease
you and everyone's like well then here's
what it is and then they were like no
but that's not what it is like we know
we would like you know what you have to
do to find out what it is wait a minute
you just I can't wait like a minute and
then you'll find out wait a minute this
is the Internet age I'm impatient i want
it now now it was just released like
more and more like teasers or more and
more jokes or whatever but like this
this seems to me like an angry backlash
like i'm sick of reading my twitter feed
like short all and i think it's because
like reputable or reputable news like
comic book news sources are saying like
hey guess what it is it is a reboot
here's what's going to happen
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh and they're like
what do you do it like you're not DC you
don't have any affiliation with us i
guaranteed that's a lot of what it was
cuz bleeding cool the gossip kings of
calming news was a political or is it
kind of really like Santa ray burst
here's all of our evidence and you're
like it myself just said rich it's not a
reboot but said underneath the freaking
like Kurt yeah it's just like Geoff
Johns like given the bird like they look
the roll back the curtain this is
rebirth the chip double flipping off the
camera my favorite bit from this ad chat
to actually be probably a tweet from Dan
Slott we just met Murray's like yeah you
know DC rebirth it's not a reboot it's
just a series of new number ones and a
brand new role it's a boot it's not a
reboot or it's a Marvel now yeah it's a
hit or too much an all-new all different
horrible did you know I say that on the
aldi well Gail Simone got in on him and
said basically the same thing it's
awesome you know how many questions that
get on the all new all different
Avengers is this 6 2016 10 or is it 6 16
it's neither there one now
one thing we don't even and you know
they don't even know like we were
talking about how they kind of fold it
in Miles Morales world into the sink
into the Marvel prime but like we don't
know what stayed what didn't like maker
stayed and we guess that miles state
because he gave oh and a burger but like
for all we know that he's right in like
6 16 and 16 and six 16 are all one
universe and there's like all kinds of
elements that like overlapped but if
that were the case Nick Fury would be
cool and not Nick Fury jr. it would just
be ultimate Nick theory and not-stupid
fate phony retcon Nick Fury yeah yeah
yeahs a whole bunch of times and they
came to bring him dick jr. and it's like
it's like it's like who you had the
chance I'm waiting for them to answer
him help him being chained up in the
moon [ __ ] so I been done like that
they don't I bet that's it I bet that's
all yeah that's that's never gonna
happen again literally like he's just
destined to watch and it's like what he
died when the multiverse collapse what
every time that's the other that cares
it's funny what they're doing with red
skull red skull who was prisoner of
Doctor Doom at the end of axis is just
walking around now he's fine well cuz I
know it's you know what I'll tell you
exactly what happened bit like they
ignored access post axis except for a
superior arm and a couple of things and
they've literally gotten rid of every
axis remnant like that they're literally
going oh no it went original sin Secret
Wars I don't know what the axes you're
talking about saber tooth is still
inverted I don't think we saw havoc
again even though they made it out like
havoc was gonna be a big new villain and
then we just never saw havoc again yeah
but saber tooth is less inverted now and
more just trying to live up over ins
name right which is actually not bad no
it's not i want to say what i'm saying
is they are literally acting like axis
didn't happen it yes it just didn't
happen yeah there's well they are
they're keeping their keeping like the
aftermath but not the story like nobody
cares about the Rhinestone carnage
statue or like I care about the
Rhinestone car hartley's brown and
fighting werewolf Jameson's son and
venom with antitoxin or somebody in am I
don't even know any its venom ya know he
has BS hoxton 00 and they're fighting a
Cthulhu cult because apparently the
lulu cult thinks that carnage will bring
about the return of the old ones
whatever i love how they just like
carnage is back don't question it right
haha six times like century ripped him
in half and then they were like he's
back wasn't he ripped in half no well no
he was but then like the Cynthia kept
him alive and regrew his legs later
there yeah FCB excuse i'm wise wise poor
Flash Thompson donut hahaha just grows
there you know they're just like waiting
it just like yeah we'll do that
eventually when it becomes convenient
for flash to be like a wounded veteran
we'll we'll just throw it that's like
his only character trade at this point
oh yeah I'm a wounded vet who
understands how the army works like that
and he's a former football star so when
in doubt he'll give you a rousing speech
about football like the young face so
much character for him as agent venom
and now they're like a venom space night
he's cool again yeah he's he was it cool
that said by the way of speaking of like
those movie that's already movies I
would watch an agent venom already me
too I'd what I don't want to see like a
venom like blair is in spite of eddie
brock and go right to the more
interesting one please you can even like
yeah that's fine me anyway but yeah f
axis if you take nothing else away from
this in our conversation about DC relax
isocell now one thing we know for
certain that will be happening as a
result of DC rieber than this new roll
out and everything we talked about it a
little last week and it bears repeating
here it's official now scott snyder will
depart Batman as of issue 51 and in fact
the solicitations came out for Batman 52
today and Tynan is writing that one no
word if he's gonna stay as the writer or
if this is a stopgap no no they've
already announced the new writer for
Batman one is that official is it so Tom
actually I was just gonna say like
actually I don't know bleeding cool's
headed off camera we were talking about
a margarita it's gonna take over what
awesome Wonder Woman possibly yeah yeah
because of what like what news said that
there was just a a blog post on bleeding
cool that said Margaret Bennet's gonna
start writing this thing now like
no quote tweet because she's doing
really good on bombshells that's Alyssa
she's great bombshells awesome wood
board Margaret Bennett crush it on on a
one-room look of course is it a
no-brainer yes is it news is it true no
not until one of them says it right now
that said the scott snyder leak we don't
like scott snyder departing Batman it
was like yeah we heard that three weeks
ago but again we're gone conclusion yeah
but again we only heard that because
like copula couldn't shut up about
leaving and uh and enrich Johnson said
fixing for a guy who was leaving on good
terms I just wanted to get a break he
was all about I'm about guys I'm out I'm
done yeah yeah leaving I am leaving yeah
exactly well okay but I don't blame him
though I mean if he was wanting to take
a break yeah oh ya know if you want to
take a break but I don't think he wants
to go draw other stuff that's not Batman
that it makes us any which is gonna kind
of suck because I mean I don't know man
it's it's what is weird things because
there are there and I hate to like you
know sound like the hipster guy but
there are times when like a writer and
an artist just mesh yeah like they just
click well this is one of those time
this was one of those times oh yeah no
doubt it just worked out well well like
Greco pillows born to draw Batman and
spawn yes and he's done both and like
I've having seen his Justice League in
super heavy or whatever I was like yeah
I would rather watch a drug I would
rather look at your Batman wreak upon if
you happen to see this scholar Saul
believes that you are defined by your
ability to draw them yeah like if you do
happen to see this I love your work and
would love just like coffee with you
sometime that they're really awesome I
incredible is watching this you are a
great artist and were a very strong man
also I will I said yes you're grateful
okie and Joel love you very very
awkwardly really hello God you had to go
creepier with it I already creeped it up
yeah I pule oh by the way Greg Capullo
I'd like to tell us all about the Batman
just tell us all about it but I yeah I
mean it's kind of sad to see Snyder
and I was thinking about this the other
night he's been writing Batman for as
long as I have been making YouTube
videos but yeah that make you were him
old are an ad that's a good question
I'll leave that for the can you say he
was using making YouTube videos like
eight years he has been writing it for
eight well gay okay when new 52 Batman
it's Ron not counting the stuff he did
before in detective comics and black me
or I'll give you that one doesn't say
eight years joel you're such a great
ears like grant morrison's been writing
comics longer than some of us have been
alive it's true that's very true which
explains why he's crazy all right guys
before we move on to the next one though
I do we need to do our usual plug but
this time the plug is gonna be for Rob's
viewers over on his channel if you want
to catch this live streaming live then
make sure you come check out twitch.tv
backslash eligible monster every tuesday
at six pm eastern that's the time ago
live i guess that's right okay guys once
they will catch the show exactly it want
to enjoy more gameplay than me myself
and myself in elgin monster from soccer
can do it we've been doing gaming monday
tuesday went well monster from sonic
okay yeah yeah that yeah this girl she's
a girl she plays games uh remains
nautical candy from eligible monster
thank you that one I either way uh
Monday Tuesday Wednesday we are playing
games over here we do it after the
weekly poll or we do it at the weekly
pulls time stamp which is about 6 p.m.
eastern and if you really do what if you
really really really love this podcast
if you want to support us live guys we
are trying to get a hundred subscribers
right now on this channel we appreciate
every single one of the subscribers and
if you can't describe just give us a
follow because following really helps us
to that we're trying to really build out
this twitch channel properly and we're
trying to turn this podcast into a more
professional podcast if Joel would
upload it properly on time but I machole
temperature okay I call about half an
hour before it starts so I'm always on
time alls I'm saying guys is if you do
enjoy this podcast we would appreciate
subscriptions on the twitch channel and
if you can't do that a follow really
does help us that's all we need and if
you are watching this on Rob's Channel
please come check it out on twitchtv
backslash
monster where you can join the chat and
we will answer your questions live
sitting here at six pm eastern I don't
know if we'll answer your questions but
we'll talk that's the answer some of the
questions thank you yeah one who is
currently following we actually have a
bottom that tells us with you a follower
some now yeah I was like whoa what's
happening mr. it's very exciting I've
been doing a lot of fixes to this twitch
channel why you guys why you guys run
off and talk comics that's that's crazy
man because I never noticed it see ya no
I do only started this last week what
the follow train what what what Rob
don't this you fighter I'll kick your
butt no way dude is you guys hear about
how do i go got beat by rap artist no
really that's the thing that happens yes
thing that happen Daigo for those who
don't know is like the king of street is
I'm is good guy here's the street
fighter guy he is like his god tier 2 he
is the different he's like the hand from
Starcraft back in the day he is the
definitive street fighter guy and he's
like it's considered his game like he's
the king of our cage arcade games and
some some rapid against challenger
wasn't like that he won 3-2 and it was
like wow it was insane but anyway so
back on topic because we're so nobly off
topic is not even funny uh what we were
next was our next up was about what well
I guess we kind of already talked about
this but I was gonna say that yeah
playing street fair that's next on the
agenda I was gonna say Deadpool breaks
r-rated movie records we basically
already talked about that we talked
about how there's kind of a arms race
going on for are rated comic book movie
the other said hey baby x4 should be
r-rated no really you think yeah well
I'm like yeah I'd be on board for that
that's something I hope they understand
like there are some movies it there are
some movies and characters that need to
be all red like any movie the features
they're dead pool needs to be r-rated
just because of the nature of Deadpool
and that's what people are going to
respect you that's the problem now is is
you know when it comes to Deadpool like
this this box has been opened you can't
make another movie with that will end of
this pg-13 because there is chimichanga
box has been opened yeah why people want
to see this Deadpool they want to see
this rental in figure do it it's just it
would have to be careful and he would
have to be used sparingly like wooden
wouldn't Xmen apocalypse be improved by
a cameo from dead
all I think they have to be rushing that
out now i'm sure it's set 20 years the
past so I don't know about that like I
don't know how we do time travel cable
time travel I would be amazed you know
the wouldn't do something like there
Lily be a scene were like dead for
sitting in his house and the cable shows
up like way we have to go body slide by
to you and they just show up in the
1980s if that was the PS if they
announced to cable was in the ps4 Xmen
apocalypse I would give them extra five
dollars yeah you always just call them
excuse me Sunni Fox like five more
dollars I or something I know I just put
an envelope right Fox on it just put in
the mailbox just mail it just feel like
walking off plane a fighter what's wrong
with that because if you mail cash now
that'll definitely make it fun you
should I selling yeah yeah right out of
monsters the US were like are you
talking about well I hope they get Steve
Lang to play cable that dude from avatar
cuz he looks like the guy let's talk
about that because I I made a poster
made like a little mock-up Time magazine
thing and like I wanted it on reddit and
then President to read it like one
person to slightly because they ate
their life and then other people were
like this is an awesome idea because
they love their life and so they were
like this this is really interesting so
it's got like a hundred votes up along
those lines which I'm happy about I mean
it feels a comparison to my 28,000 you
know karma points process which I'm very
happy about but nonetheless so I when I
had when I made the video on cables
words I told people like I think liam
neeson should be the one to play hit one
that was my first thought sitting in the
theater was just made a Liam Neeson
choked with things exactly there's a big
Liam Neeson joke in there and I kept
thinking about it as the after he said
and I was like I could definitely see
him I mean you could you can see that
dichotomy like the super serious you
know Liam Neeson and Deadpool destiny
Sookie's a Gannett Wade you know if
shalini singh does do commie usually
it's terrible commonplace die in the
west why don't you do it but yes but but
the good thing is it would be like Liam
Neeson from taken meet suede is how is
how he would come across we don't have a
particular set of time travel skills
doesn't know people like you people have
that lawful not American accent where is
like who knows how many fathoms good I
must solve some cattle and that would
have a particular cybernetic eye
eh but i have no noise it makes a nice
there for people like you protection I
could see you even if you have clothes
on but nonetheless so I can't wait for
Deadpool to just do would do away with
Deadpool's complicated with cables
complicated origin story me just like
hey kids it's cable he's the son of you
know Scott Summers and Jean Grey from
the future yeah it's all I need to know
really thanks I mean somebody yeah
somebody was actually met asking me out
on Instagram today they were like what
are they gonna do how are they gonna do
is origin I'm like he's Jean Grey and
Scott Summers kid from the future drop
all clones and you have a really
streamlined version of Saudi origin it's
the origin that I remember and talk
about and then of course the common
threads like oh you left out these
clothes and I'm like at the end of the
day cable is their kid from the future
well before people who see this on
youtube star freaking out Madeline prior
there you go okay anyway so what is that
prior is she a clone of Jean Grey Jean
Grey so freaking Jean Grey no little bit
no shoes at all she's a totally like she
went crazy and she tried to take over
the world using genetically disney
goblin queen what ya got my way
nonetheless like all like let's say is
WTF oh wait hashtag [ __ ] the x-men the
[ __ ] up and coming what Janice so anyway
Ron is continuing in now people words
people kept saying more and more often
like Stephen Lang should be cable and
some people were saying is less like the
guy looks just like the guy and I
started going through looking at like
different pictures you know I even would
like to watch avatar well you made a
supercell regular pictures that you keep
up your pillow I have I have a
scrapbooker stephen letting like Stephen
Lang I have a scrapbook of you a very
particular scrap boilers you need a lot
about receiving a lot of people watch
this podcast subscribe and book a
scrapbook that makes me nightmare Mitch
leaks yet whatever lemurs Downey jr. if
you're watching this I'm volunteering to
be your PA perfectly free I'll do it for
free thank you i would do Robert
attitude would be like the coolest
person to work for you like and you
don't get me like a or maybe the most
horrible person to work my point is
don't you she would be a cool guy like
hey can you go grab me a coffee by the
way feel free to get yourself like a
Maserati asleep awesome we're gonna make
another oh oh you guys are in some funny
speaking of Maseratis rob called me and
says why don't we buy a private jet
together I was goofin I was goofing
around like I couldn't tell if you were
goof or not he was like it's just my
private like yeah Ronnie Oh sir private
jet is a sock our money together and buy
a several hundred million dollar of a
your check like jewels totally serious
idea of buying a used like you know tour
bus or RV and tour around North America
going to I would do that I will bore
that well Robin are doing that in March
Oh everything I go start booking that
okay i do not even know if that was
still happening i'll try to go it's the
first week of a prove Rob and I on the
first week of paper will be traveling
from whatever the top of the New England
is I always mix it up I always think
Vermont but it's not Vermont that really
cool place up there in the northern
gonna play something stopped her from
there now screw Disney World we're to
stop a comic book stories and hang out
with all of our friends will avoid comic
pop though because it makes too much
sense in every won't expect us to show
up right you know haul ass on all the
way to lollapalooza like they did on
that what simpsons episode if you guys
are gonna have to like follow us make
sure you follow us on twitter comic
story comments explaining what all that
stuff so that end NK patrol so that you
guys so that we can be like hey guys
like we're hanging out you can be like
okay cool and then you're gonna go to
Burning Man and burn the man man hope
you like i wish i was there but uh no
yeah because you are actually the whole
thing is Rob Rob needs to eat food from
the east coast ah skin the main laughter
he's gonna go gay Austin shouta he's
gonna make me lobstery limite toes
coming down there we all know I'm in
Connecticut cuz i'm going to have
anything really nothing great mmm but
anyway anyway so so yes back back to the
topic at hand rom no so the more people
said it the more i started looking at
different images of Stephen Lang and I
was like yeah like this guy would be a
great cable and you know I'm curious
like for those of you in the chatter
watching this right now those you guys
are see this on youtube post on it and
who you guys think you know should be
the one to play cable I'm curious who if
you guys could pick anybody to play
cable who would you guys pick Arnold
Schwarzenegger in just serious Jocasta
like Schwarzenegger now dogged that who
was go back in time to the extra any Ron
Perlman would be all gasp it would show
that he would be okay he did sons of
anarchy he basically just looked like
cable just strapping I to him an arm to
him and there you go well I'm even if
you go and watch him in um in Pacific
Rim he look like me look like a
dressed-up cable yeah animals now yeah
which the areas weird name damn shoe
animals dude I love that lie that was
such an awesome scene to give us at the
end of the movie yeah I love like this a
memorable Chinese not even sort of asian
nobody else all right here's one thing
that the people were talking about
because when I when I post it up on
reddit somebody was like well he's just
way like he's much shorter than I was to
make any sense you might as well cast on
cruise likely use camera also was no
Jack McHugh Jackman was shorter than
Reynolds to he had to have special lifts
in his shoes just to make him look the
same time oh you think it would be a
little shorter than let the next
Wolverine actor be a little Wolverine do
like a little Rhino Riley guy yeah yeah
but see then he's not intimidating he's
not skillets he's a point that he can
mess you up even while he's tiny yeah
he's scary punches up but he punches up
with claws yes knives to come out of his
eyes is that not intimidating enough for
you raha I'm on I'll be honest man like
that's not very scary to me because I
was like well I have nice to sure
they're not made of an indestructible
metal but they stayed do your jobs see
there you go but he'll then he'll her
little body at you and now for instance
what it's like well you know what will
rain like yes your skull like your
entire skeleton is made of adamantium
but you know what's not made of
adamantium your eyeballs so we're just
gonna stab you in the eyes yeah and then
you're gonna die why he's been eating
steer yeah finally my god I had a whole
yogurt in the time it took us to have
this Wolverine conversation Benny ate a
whole yogurts crush of that yogurt just
Angela good Betty Jersey me over like
you know
absolutely destroyed a yogurt just not
there oh man I got some of that dark
night uh vs Batman cereal that they're
coming out all day honey Tiffany just
said I'm screaming had a voted I in to
the weekly pool you can go good hey why
is gonna be that on this episode we her
down a fifth member we are yeah she's
working on stuff plus like Tiffany we
demand you oh we didn't invite her
that's why good well you always have an
open invitation Tiffany you don't come
on Tiffany yeah you're that Tiffany
hahaha wow sounds so excited that sounds
like yeah you're that Tiffany you have
an open invitation alright this is the
most off-topic episode we've had in a
long time yes anyway we have any topics
we need a house we needed a falsa fact I
am doing it what does them and Joel's
like yeah and and and it's almost like
we had a person who worked really hard
to come up with a whole bunch of really
good cuz topics we're going through them
I'm sorry you can pay them away yeah
we're just room so we're making our way
through a man yeah so making away Denton
so here's another one I guys we can all
just a suppression roll down hey uh
everyone everyone I need you to do me a
favor right now this is legitimate cuz I
because you because you like to tweet
people what I tell you not to so this
one I need you to do I need you all to
tweet faust right now with hashtag faust
effect you've ruined the podcast just
say that like ruined forever he just
jumped in on skype faster screwed it up
man well we got Tiffany's hair us cute
if he getting tagged in yeah tagging
she's gonna go off the ropes hey
everyone what while we're getting
Tiffany and I need you to tweet Faust at
ya this link you share the probation oh
and why wrap tweet hashtag fast effect
you ruin the weekly pool and then
hashtag [ __ ] rock yeah you know while
you're out there doing stuff for me you
know well you look while you're at it
you all to buy a Maserati and deliver
them to rob uh cause Ronnie's army
Maseratis guys at the
come off your hands are problems like
too many cooks but too many Maseratis
yeah but just Rock what am I gonna do Oh
Judy I was doing the weekly poll I got
say on the Maserati conversation at the
school that I work out I have seen more
of those vehicles and I thought I ever
would yeah yeah we're gonna private
schools so you know so I almost no not
Monica so I went to go buy a mustang
when I got out of the army I was like oh
this is this is warm before there's
something article by Mustang everyone in
the military as a Mustang out what a
Mustang so I show up there and my wife's
like no we can't have a Mustang we need
a Corvette like scored a triple the
amount of a Mustang yeah yeah corpus for
you but now let me ask you this was it a
cherry red Mustang was it cheer not
neither i got a highlander dough to rise
living my life man father can we only
want you now so yeah well my buddy are
you getting irritated cuz I keep pulling
us off track no no I mean like this is
the show man that's how are you today
I'm super great are you good yep are you
really just coming out this week right
so what what are your viewers get to
look forward to uh me all the time
Tiffany's heading up the episode of back
issues on Thursday isn't gonna like pick
up Sokka again are you gonna do it again
ginger saga again ya gotta get ethan and
Ben you know they have time to recoup
yeah they got sick or something no I'm
in for I'm saga oh yeah yeah yeah Cecily
oh we're on comments like they were like
hey r are you gonna do sorry I'm like
nope that's cause I don't know what this
video's like are you gonna do suck I'm
like that is long there's a reason why I
don't do that kind of thing it was a
reason why I jealous on earth to right
now as a jewel how goddamn longer to
Indian right there was no sex tilia it's
so scary there you know what i will do
saga and i will do in a single issue per
episode and put them all of one at a
time back to back one day you'll just
have like 40 freakin episodes go on oh I
would do it every day but I do it every
week I don't know what the questions
about I need like a long car trip or a
plane ride for to catch up on
saga from the beginning yeah there's a
new saga every week I don't know my
plane rides are typically except fly
around so much at this point it's to
read every comment came out the week
yeah I've often said they may have it
read all the turtles books all the idw
nice most of ever i'm gonna do how'd I
just can't I want to read all the
turtles books but they're so freaking
many there are no what they're you know
what am i doing they are really good the
only parolee I did not enjoys when they
went to another dimension to protect
elves that kraang was attacking I was
like whoa whoa like Christmas elves are
like there's like a nobler a lease in
the comic at this time around and kraang
is fleeing from a war with them to try
and get technology from the turtles
that's what the that was the whole point
of the buter jit so what has been
happening is he once they figure this
out the turtles go to the dimension the
kraang's attacking and they help the
elves okay that it and that is the real
secret of views you aren't now I'm the
only one that read about kraang fighting
the elves with the top of the turtles I
think you might have dreamed that that's
real yeah I'm gonna google that real
quick I did the one the turtle arcs that
I like is when they went to another
dimension of hung out with Batman and
it's great oh I know I'm really enjoying
it it's making me want to go back and
read all the turtles I do I like what
you know you know it's really you could
skip the elf arc you just do all the
intro stuff the shredder stuff skip the
kraang stuff come back when they kill
Donatello cuz you haven't yeah yeah yeah
I heard all I mean like trust me there
you couldn't jump on Twitter without
finding out Donatello died my favorite
turtle yeah you know I'm gonna carve out
a day I cuz I was originally I
originally had a day to do a whole bunch
of like like to do a series of DC
stories I'm gonna like cancel those and
do ninja turtles like one video a week
everyone yeah I can't give up with it
I've gotten to a point now where once a
week I'm trying to do indie or other
publishers and that kind of a thing we
just did birthright and I'm doing
another truly ND on saturday cuz their
book just came out it's actually really
good where's well I Monday I'd anything
i want to write blue valiant stuff it's
called dead dance parties from darby pop
I actually actually got I'm not gonna
lie they said it to me I was like I
really don't think
I really don't think it's gonna fly guys
and so I sat down at reddit and it's
about an assassin who's like the best at
his game and then what he ends up doing
is he gets diagnosed with cancer and in
his line of work this is thing called
the dead man's parties you can go out on
top of your game you can put it out
there that you five of your peers can go
out and kill you you'll be the best of
the best they'll get your bank account
in your name on the resume and that is
so awesome that's right way con sucked
then he discovers he doesn't have cancer
the whole thing was so that he would
study with dead man's party and there's
no way to call it off that's cool social
suicide so it's like the most dangerous
game meets the game little bit yeah
let's meet Scott the disposable assassin
göransson no it's a really good book so
i'm putting that on a saturday cuz
they're the book just released in amazon
so I'm like hey guys the book came out
go check it out it's solid yeah and I I
wish I had more time to keep up with all
these cool indie books I always say the
only time I'll get to read those is if
I'm on a trip or if I go to prison and I
have unlimited time to just sit and they
look if you comics in prison my friend I
hate I don't know who's little bit drop
cuz you love my dares I'm looking at the
comments right now I dare you dare you
dare you dare you and I will do the vine
that I promised you or I say Rob is God
and put it up on my Twitter if you do
idw's my little pony that's like that's
like you gotta do it like are you
serious yes yeah you just cuz if you do
it I will you can go say this is the
Dare I'm doing it on a dare I'm fine
with that but if you do it no he's been
legit a big my little pony Fanny is then
does dig while ponies fate he has a
favorite he watched the show he doesn't
read the comics but did pick them up on
frequent public okay so that's real
that's not like some lore you made up
like that's legit okay no sprinted
because of the people who made it were
the same people who did like powerpuff
girl so it's like yeah it's probably one
of us all right this is not is gonna be
a dumb question asked how many people in
the chat think that I should do my
little pony how many people w how many
of you think that should take up any
honest air let the tractor saw yeah we
know what we will cut the story I it'll
be like gladiator you give thumbs up or
thumbs down up again that is it oh my
gosh did you chained by these ponies no
by the way I said oh my gosh oh I'll do
my little pony Oh use your voice if he's
so much better in what would mind be
like very Sparkle whatever I don't know
Twilight Sparkle Twilight's Marshall
flew in and saved the day from all right
well then I'll do my na all our
friendship was magic it was an all
postponed uh man it's gonna be such a
terrible idea I will postpone my what
does everyone like oh my cable videos um
no yeah sorry cable you're getting Joel
for ponies hope you like Joel post one
everything by a week and I'll do my
little pony on front okay woohoo
everyone I got an extra week I'm having
drawn by the script fri or for Aquaman
explain yeah don't really well actually
it's one of the better things I've
written oh my god there's a lot of
history in seventh already regretting
his decision no no this is this is
actually to see that this is why isn't
this is he's already bored and looking
up her laptop this is how this is how
this region is not me oh there's no this
week is gonna play out we're gonna go
we're gonna I'm running over the
evolution of ice man's powers and marvel
comics and then we're doing faith faith
explained I'm never doing then we're
doing my little pony and then we're
doing one of those videos on the
incredible hulk so we're gonna go from a
dude that literally can control the
molecules of things in existence to a
female chick who's a superhero two
ponies to the edible Hulk because that's
the evolution of our sounds like an
awesome club yeah lets the evolution
evolution of our tweets that sounds like
a party everyone wants to go to yeah
like it's something it's gonna be cool
but my week is uh try to think only 10
Green Lantern tomorrow is Superboy
because we couldn't get out
original plan to dirt Vader video so we
got Superboy coming out then I have I
just weren't the middle of podcast /
just like I really expect that thursday
is evil Superman destroying earth to
that's basically what that basically
vol.5 in its entirety that's a story I
like that story happy friday is Batman
your ropa oh that's a great story
y'all's gonna wait is already finish
those wheels and its overall really damn
it all the new excellent story Luther is
Batman V Superman prequel Lois Lane and
OJ's party yep Devin haha I just sundays
out there yes o hoani pon1 take your six
foot tall as madagascar here my little
pony comic oh my god we have no
wednesday guys we're just call this poem
there's no my god this comic is called
friendship is magic yes it happens
underscore for my little pony it's
called Pinal Pony friends was magic do
you not agree with that sentiment uh
friendship friendship is magic with this
man but when you say it though when you
have any more topics Joel just not
accurate I mean anyway we're talking
about cars and Maseratis before or so
this is only fitting a bumblebee is
going to be getting a spinoff from the
Transformers movie and 28 th illustrated
the leaves that is no different than
like the tow truck from cars getting one
or door getting one from from that
finding whatever they need emo yeah find
a damn fish I do without yourself I just
need a higher cell to follow me round to
finish my sentences I loved it in a
series where they can barely concentrate
on the few robot characters they
actually do have their ideas let's take
out more the robot characters and just
have warm let's let's not make it about
up miss prime the only one that anyone
wants to watch an action and making
about the one robot the can't freaking
talk for no reason yeah okay also those
movies are terrible so never well so
just as a free until the latest one the
cast of this comic book the
personalizing 10 is still on my own it's
it's toilet over Princess Celestia yeah
yeah see I
Applejack Oh what is it Ellis alicious a
delicious delicious apple Jody so well i
will i'm sorry just don't like it very
much when i tried watching the first
episode like this is too sad the pilots
death but there's other couple episodes
that are pretty funny i'ma one like they
do like a big parody of batman the
animated series there's painted they did
a big lebowski episode is gonna be a lot
in google it oh my god it really tied
the room together yeah this okay this
video is gonna go one of two ways either
like say what you want about nationalism
like 40,000 people are gonna watch it it
will easily wanna be like or it'll be
like a million people will watch it be
be more animated and you're like I am
gonna like it if this turns it to be
your highest video ever you end up
having to do like a weekly my little
pony I am gonna do nothing but laugh at
you Wow yeah we can laugh me while I'm
working in the views I'm just as you say
those looking laughing all the way to
the bank picture rocks it may be like
man those ponies they moved me into a
bigger house well it's gonna be weird
too because it is gonna be focusing on
like how the ponies feel like that next
time I'm no no no now wait a minute if
I'm gonna do a crop my little pony by
god you're gonna let me talk about it
like I you know what I'm going balls to
the wall life I'm nominee for a throne
oceans how I think was feeling how I
think they might be the world like the
whole nine you're at while it was in got
my little pony this also means you're
gonna have to probably watch it lease
the pilot for the show to get them
context for the characters and get the
voice is right in your head I'm not
gonna do voices but my voice is Rob
never does what you don't do voices dude
I don't do since jazz me identify I have
five voices that I rotate but I have a
power and a half with Zod achill from
our gaming channel that is now a thing
after every weekly poll we will be here
afterwards and we'll be hanging out here
and stuff like that this particular
episode I don't think any I think
everyone's like ready to bolt
so Sal gets grumpy face and we go over
time like a frumpy cat like oh yeah
dinner's on the stove just it's been
warm it's fun I know I'm bummed oh
that's why I'm like uh no I know I don't
and that's why I'm always like oh look
at the time South should have gone an
hour ago alright guys so uh just for
those you guys you've just joined this I
am bending the comic story and i run the
channel comic story and i also do stuff
on the channel eligible monster it's a
gaming channel comic book channel we do
lures storylines goof around have fun
it's just we get you caught up a gig
content i want you guys all do a fresh
pitch because honestly who knows how
many people Rob's got with the channel
know they have no idea we are right so
hello everybody I'm south this is
tiffany we're from comic pop it's a it's
just a comic book channel we talk about
comics and we do reviews and discussions
and it's just all of our personalities
on display where we just share our
opinions and feelings about comics and
our flagship show back issues is the
show where I explain comics or two
people who have no idea what's happening
or have any context for it I usually
pick a really continuity heavy story so
there's a lot of tangents inside stores
inside conversations it's usually humor
based a lot of fun hopefully i'll check
it out the last episode was spider verse
this week we're doing an episode which
in which tiffany will be taking the lead
she is leading the show on that episode
where she's going to talk about dr. doom
Doctor Strange triumphant torment which
is an amazing graphic novel where those
two Titans team up and battle the forces
of Hell Channel watch that one on spider
verse it's it's fun because I know you
hated spider verse I got a good to say
about it it ranged himself in pretty
good honestly i give you the great
imagine restraint by joy that's uh well
i'm joel and you can find me over on the
candle cape Joel I don't actually review
comics I'm a heroin-addicted jazz critic
so if you want to know about the newest
Coltrane please come on over to cave
Joel and I'll tell you all about it
later the week I'm gonna be eating some
cereal i watch the Hat I'm actually not
joking about the cereal if you want to
see me eat that new bat MV super cereal
I'm gonna be doing that later in the
week
a new series i'm thinking of calling
caped kitchen know what I curios I just
thought I will take that dear sir that
video is happening nice haven't filmed
it yet but it's happening and everyone
Rob let's assume and no let's pretend
for a minute this is it on your channel
10 this also goes up an itunes and we
have 300 viewers right now who may or
may not know what the hell's going on so
I want you to why don't you promote
yourself for a minute uh well the
omega-level mutant is uh going on
tomorrow that's ice cream from are you
you selling yourself as explained oh
okay oh we're marketing okay this also
goes up in itunes and it also goes up on
on the twitch as a backlog so maybe
someone want might watch this and not
know who you are okay I was like I was
like what in the world goes up my
channel uh yeah guys all comers to
explain um just here to basically help
you guys get a better understanding of
the Marvel and DC Universe um tomorrow
I'm focusing on Omega level mutants
which is the highest classification of
powers of for mutants of Marvel Comics
and we're going to talk about Iceman and
why it is that his powers make him an
omega-level mutant which fun fact hemal
ups the manipulates molecules what up
and then faith from valiant college
which is uh really like the first
overweight superhero I think by the
first what size that with her own [ __ ]
ya know my name is a personal book she's
the first one who is fine with her
weight she wasn't unless you pick Big
Bertha from the Great Lakes event that's
what i thought i'd let say like there
are other ones busty like like like big
bertha made everybody mad because she's
a supermodel whose power is to eat a ton
of food and get fat yeah that's her
power and so like she regurgitates at
all and she's actually normal for me ok
it's not it's not it's not a good oh you
see and then apparently i'm doing my
little pony on friday apparently dead
and i'm making a fine this is rob is
gone hey wait hang on Rob what's your
cutie mark oh he doesn't know working
haha what is you oh yeah here's a new I
don't know what that is Heath it look I
know exactly what his cutie mark would
be it's yeah it's a bait machine is what
it is I just John Mark it's a week we
Shore for just a cloud that's what I was
thinking was a cloud okay hold on a
cutie marks premiere he's baby mony i'm
writing on that no guys we will see you
next week right here if you want to hang
around i'll be playing some street
fighter 5 after this we can chat about
comic books we can chat about Street
Fighter we could chat about awesomeness
whatever sounds got to go eat jolson
thing he's got to go drink beer and Rob
do babe word all right guys yeah so
we'll we'll catch you guys later please
search later all right are we not like
no no we're live on my side still okay
killin it they can listen to us so talk
rap [ __ ] rob prep oh oh really did do
they really kill it it would for the
record we are actually still live there
listening to the post-show for well
they're laid out the post-show there's a
splash page talk about it on the show
was it but is that is the poll really
dead yeah supposedly supposedly it is
dead actually I remember hearing rumors
about that stuff before him to can we
then scoop the name and not feel bad
about oh yeah cuz cuz those bands called
kiss before the band called kiss that we
all know so yeah it doesn't matter who
did it first just matters who did it
better that's right doesn't matter did
it first it just matters who did it best
we do the best I really can drop that
book of my lip I split it or hurts I
totally saw that I don't think you
actually did that I did it totally hurt
that's not [ __ ] reaction to that it's a
solid dog like I did and it really bad
it really did hurt for real guys like
legit you're all y'all suck being mean
to me good the laser show talk about how
would you hate us I feel I feel pretty
happy I hate some of my commenters I
don't even know I don't know his name so
I can't go like give him off but up
there I had a commoner recently who
decided to go into all of my videos and
complain that i allowed activist
to put call of duty 3 come home yeah
that guy my on my videos he was like
your big as a great but this goddamn
freaking call of duty [ __ ] you let
on your videos blah blah blah blah blah
what a guy I don't pick those ads man i
know i responded with i don't pick those
ads google pics that based on your
search history so why you looking at
call a duty content that's not true
Benny I remember you had a meeting and
you do sal that you had gotten in touch
with activision yeah yeah they were like
oh they were a call of duty four days
and you were like whatever as long as
the money's green as long as the money
few dollars from call of duty melina my
lambo's black just like yeah man like
army are you are you trying to get on
the whole lead scopes you know Austin
I'm a 360 number guy with a KD of an
impressive number of 1.2 nuclear lag
killed me brah the lag yeah I I could
totally be MLG if I wanted to I just
don't wanna uh dank night v how quickly
do you get that the pull up on the
weekly pull on itunes of joel barn i
usually try and do it as soon as Rob
puts it up on his channel I grab the
audio you normally like a day behind
putting it on the channel right Ross
asking what its gonna go oh yeah it
should be up tomorrow okay I thought you
were still talking control and then I
will grab it as soon as Rob puts it up
and I will do it as soon as i can after
that okay guys I gotta go get ready
they're gonna go eat and stuff like that
I know brah sounds like why are we still
talking because we were iconic family
I'm gonna put on some music we'll be
back in 15 minutes playing some games
you stick around I love you all thank
you so much don't forget to follow the
channel if you want to know whenever we
go live with the podcast which goes on
Tuesdays and Thursdays now I will figure
out how we're gonna do it me salen
Varenne Joel will do a podcast that will
be constantly promoted and being awesome
and we'll get a macaron so I will
literally be on a podcast just about
every day during the week yeah basically
and and and we will be playing games i
make sure you follow so you can see when
that happens and we really do appreciate
anyone who subscribe come on agree on
that podcast if you want to you can you
have to read comics from because we all
know Rob reads
comics at all yeah that'll relieve the
second episode the pole I don't recover
be just change them anyways like if you
do give us a subscription it does
directly support the guys on the weekly
poll that money is sent to us and we do
appreciate it and anybody who wants to
subscribe we would really appreciate it
we've been doing this a year now on this
day and now we're trying to do more
stuff for you guys so I think we can
officially state we do appreciate subs
because we have been doing it yes el dia
well everybody first started people like
should we sub and we were like we don't
know if we're gonna keep doing this so
it's true that now like a year and a
half it's like yes please for the love
of God so okay guys we'll see you all in
15 minutes they're gonna take off good
good good stuff guys dr. later fight
later